[Music]
those words are forever a part of the
American lexicon thanks to Maury Povich
and after 26 years of paternity suits
and meltdowns Maury is finally being
recognized for his excellent with the
Daytime Emmy nomination so what's his
secret we'll take a look when it comes
to three-year-old Addison Cameron you
are not you are the fire
lori's paternity shows are infamous you
are not and that brings us to secret
number one he's always just as surprised
as we are I will not allow my producers
to tell me anything about the design I
want to be as surprised shocked whatever
as everybody else in the room it's hard
to believe that anything could surprise
Maury Povich at this point but that
secret number to the revelations that
shocked him two instances on the show
where when I was doing a paternity show
and this woman was accusing a man of
being the father of her twins and I read
the result and she's the father of one
but not the other when it comes to
one-month-old take Chad you are the
father
and when it comes to one-month-old
payton chad you are not apparently you
can be with paternal twins you can have
two fathers if the lady happens to be
busy during that time of the month now
up for his first Emmy Maury won't be
attending the ceremony this weekend the
reason
well that secret number three he's super
superstitious about award shows it dates
back to when his production company's
documentary about 9/11 was up for an
Oscar I made up my mind ten twelve years
ago when you were nominated I'm not
going to go to the Oscars because I know
I will put the kibosh on somehow I'll be
bad luck my wife and I were in the
Bahamas and we won the Academy Award so
that's been my mantra ever since
mauriz wife of course his former network
news anchor Connie Chung they've been
married for 32 years
his marriage advice that secret number
four when your head hits the pillow at
night all discussions I don't care how
intense they have been during the day
they must end and the next morning is a
fresh day ain't that the truth one more
secret we learned more he goes the extra
yard to make sure he pronounces every
person's name correctly think about that
even ask the guest sometimes himself